I want to start today showing you the
mayonnaise brained Insanity confusion
that plagues the minds of many of these
reflexive anti-trans homophobic types
we're going to look at a video clip of
Eric Balling on uh Newsmax is he on
Newsmax he used to be on Fox News he got
fired there I believe it's on Newsmax
now he winds together
confusion about transgenderism
people who have a handicapper disability
and racism
in a way that exposes at its core
how clueless he is
and it's just beyond words I'm like
struggling to even explain it to you let
me just play it and then we'll talk
about it the context is swimmer Leah
Thomas and this new anti-trans not new
growing anti-trans Vendetta among the
American right and Maga take a listen to
this and and try to keep your head on
straight during it if you can although
my head was spinning when I first heard
this Senator we're going to leave there
one thought for the folks to take away
you know there's a there's an MMA
fighter that is a trans to a male male
to female he's fighting or shooting it's
a trans fighting in the female Division
and he fractured the skull of the other
fighter and then one more thought
um before we go what if someone a man
decided he wanted to identify as a
handicapped person could they just win
the Special Olympics because they're
identifying we're all supposed to go
okay well let's not be uh you know
racist against trans because it it I
mean it's insane we've gone crazy
Senator Tommy tuberville thank you for
joining us there you go what if this
completely implausible scenario came
true then what would you do Senator then
what would the woke left say this
reminds me of a very
um astute
uh statement once made by an Italian
chef if my grandmother had Wheels she
would be a bicycle but of course she
didn't she was a person so what is being
first of all the phrase racist against
trans is hilarious what we're talking
about is discrimination not racist
against trans this guy's just he doesn't
know what's going on
um but the analogy is between gender
expression and disability
and this is quite frankly idiotic we're
talking about two completely different
aspects of human experience and you
really can't liken one to the other when
we talk about gender expression we're
talking about the external manifestation
of gender identity it might align with
your sex at Birth or it might not trans
aside there is a spectrum where you
would say here are biological females
and they have varying levels of
femininity here are biological males and
they have varying levels of masculinity
now if you imagine these as two
overlapping bell curves there is a point
in the sort of tail regions of that
curve where the biological women's
expression would actually be more
masculine than that of some men okay so
the point is we're talking about that
when we talk about trans people we're
not talking about what disability is a
physical or mental impairment that might
limit your ability to perform a certain
task engage in a certain activity it's a
completely different framework
altogether trans people might Express
gender identity in different ways
clothing hairstyles mannerisms other
things these are informed by cultural
norms and expectations in society about
what it means to be masculine or
feminine feminine they vary from person
to person they're very different in
different cultures trans people are
often experiencing distress or
discomfort when their gender expression
doesn't align with their internal sense
of self and there's all these other
things when you claim to to identify as
a handicapped person despite having no
actual disability or limitation
it's not valid or legitimate as an
expression of identity it's
disrespectful it trivializes the
experiences of people with disabilities
who often by the way are facing all
sorts of barriers to participating in
society this is similar to when the
homophobes used to say if two men can
get married can get married what's to
stop someone from marrying a horse then
you go this wait a second does that make
sense what are you talking about horses
can't enter into contracts marriages are
based on two consenting adults
understanding the agreement they're
entering into horses can't do that
animals can't give informed consent they
can't enter legally binding agreements
it's at its core an argument that
doesn't make any sense and it was sort
of an attempt to link homosexuality to
bestiality quite frankly similarly
bolling's idea that a trans person is
like someone lying about a disability
is absurd and it's ridiculous and this
is the sort of analysis that we've come
to expect from use max quite frankly
I am seriously going to suggest that you
first watch or listen to this segment
before letting children hear it because
it's that disturbing I I'm just putting
it out there I want to tell you I'm
about to play a clip that is
extraordinarily disturbing this might be
the most disturbing Christian sex story
of all time this was Unearthed by uh
hemant meta who writes the friendly
atheist sub stack he's really good I
follow him on Twitter okay I am going to
play a video for you here
where Dr Glenn Hill and his wife Phyllis
Hill
uh were interviewed by Pro abstinence
girl defined co-host Bethany Beale
in this interview okay I I so I'm sorry
that we I just have to explain it in
this way there aren't there almost
aren't words enough to describe what
happens here
um
the wife of the couple
Miss Hill
describes that for a long time
she believed she had no
clitoris
and she oh my God she only found out
specifically what it is
when her friend showed her on her baby
girl
I've never seen anything like this okay
look look at this
like I was like yeah I'm broken like I
didn't even think that that was a weird
sentence
but she said okay what can you define
broken what what are you saying what
does that mean and and then I just said
oh well I don't have a clitoris
um because at this point Glenn had read
enough to know that a clitoris was
involved and uh yeah didn't know where
he was as clueless as I was but once he
accidentally stumbled upon an issue of
the New England medical journal and was
but knew that that mattered and that had
to do with an orgasm and it's like yeah
I've never orgasmed and there's no
pleasure I don't enjoy it matter of fact
I hate it wow I just endure it we just
get through it as fast as possible and
um
and so yeah we shared that openly and
she was in the medical field
and uh she was like okay well
what do you mean you don't have a
clitoris and our friend
after a bit said you know I I just feel
like taking films in the back room and
showing her what I'm talking about well
Philip started to stand up uh and then
this other woman said but I just can't I
can't do that
our oldest child had been born uh which
is a little girl and eventually uh a
fellas is changing uh our daughter's
diaper and our friend showed her on
um our little girl you know where the
clues is located which is huge
information wow for fellows and again
it's stunning to me
that's pretty darn basic folks uh
this is the moral majority right or
something like that this is I mean
cringe doesn't cover it this this is
just
I'm struggling to find the words in
maybe a different language would better
have the words for this but I'm
struggling to find the words to explain
and understand
this bizarre turn
now this video since him and found it
it was set to private
and it looks like they're trying to kind
of scrub this because this is so
completely insane now Glenn Hill
is a quote clinical sexologist
that's what he describes himself as
apparently with a PhD
how do these things happen what is
happening here where the people
least able
to actually work through and understand
and explain also I mean listen to sexual
dysfunction and of lack of uh sex said
all these different things you know
um
and these are the folks that say we are
the ones who can explain to you uh the
right how things work and the right this
it's borderline you should just check in
with child protective services and
clearly they recognize that they're
trying to scrub this video it it has
just it has creepy all over it it has
creepy all over it and you don't have to
think that anything inappropriate was
going on with a baby to just see this
and go oh that it's just I'm cringing it
just doesn't feel right what's going on
here uh and they are now doing
everything they can to make sure that
this stuff is all removed we may get hit
with some kind of copyright violation
for even surfacing this I'll keep you
posted if indeed that happens but uh
really really vile stuff quick break
back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David packman show depends on your
support we have a membership program
which you can sign up for at
joinpakman.com it includes the show we
do every day with no commercials made
Available to You hours earlier than we
publish it to everybody else as well as
a daily bonus show an extra show where
we talk about more news stories analysis
and a lot of crazy things happen on that
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted you can also use the
coupon code indicated either one will
work the discounts are slightly
different at joinpakman.com let's hear
from the most important people to the
David packman show the viewers and the
listeners we like to take calls via
Discord you can join the Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord it's an incredible thing we are
going to start calls today how about
Tristan from Washington Tristan from
Washington welcome to the David packman
show what's on your mind today
hello David can you hear me yes I can
oh good Heavens to Betsy honor it's
freck right such an honor to start the
show today the honor is all mine sir
thank you so much so a couple things
um one I've called your show a few times
before and one of the last times called
I was in Oregon I'm now moved to the
Seattle area and we had discussed on a
previous call uh chocolate babka and I
am happy to report since I have moved
here I have found two different Jewish
delis in the area
and I'm very happy I hope that I can
compare the two and give back to you
have you been to Seattle do you know
about any of these places no I haven't
but you know I follow very closely uh J
Kenji Lopez alt who does now live in
Seattle and he seems to post some great
uh food spots in Seattle the food scene
seems to be quite Lively there
oh it's it's very Exquisite I I really
can't wait to try everything
um that it has to offer it's gonna be a
great experience and I can't wait to
give you my report once I've experienced
The Culinary traditions of Seattle now
let me ask you one thing the chocolate
babka that you've seen around there
they're not putting chocolate chips on
top are they
well I so I just moved here I haven't
gotten a chance to actually go okay down
there you know like I said last time the
only Bob guy I've tried was the Trader
Joe's and they do put chocolate chips on
there yes be very very suspicious about
uh chocolate chips on top of the babka
okay that's my advice but report back
when you know more
I will definitely do so can't wait to do
it
um next question sure um
I uh so I'm a bit of a quirky guy I have
quirky beliefs and
I've been I want to take you back to the
founding of our country uh 222 years ago
when judicial review was was established
by the Supreme Court basically they gave
themselves that power and because the
Supreme Court has been in the news so
much I
and I realize this isn't actually going
to happen anytime soon but I just kind
of wanted to get your opinion do you
think
that overturning the president of
judicial review would actually solve a
lot of the problems that the court has
caused for us and following that do you
think what sort of system if you David
Pacman were the founding father of this
country what system of the for the court
do you think you would establish uh you
know I I don't on the second question I
don't know that's really more of a
question for a legal scholar I'm sure
you'll find all sorts of random
political people who will weigh in but I
really would leave that to Legal
Scholars the judicial review what what
you're talking about with judicial
review uh is essentially reviewed by the
Supreme Court of the constitutionality
of legislative acts so it's sort of a
melding of what our legislative acts
carried out by the House and Senate and
the president and then comparing and
contrasting that with the Constitution
Constitution Bill of Rights and seeing
whether it is coherent with that and it
is sort of like an ultimate final word
in a sense on the decisions that are
made by our legislators and there are
people who say well that's really a
check and a balance that's not actually
appropriate and it allows the Supreme
Court to become even political than than
we already know it's allowed to be I I
don't have a strong position as to
whether I would get rid of judicial
review what I'm more interested in is
I think that there are reforms that can
be made to the Supreme Court including
uh term limits and creating a
predetermined replacement schedule to
take out the politicization and strategy
around holding on for another year or
not I I there are other things that I
would like to change about the Supreme
Court which I've outlined in content on
the show previously which for me would
be lower hanging fruit than the the
judicial review question is really a
bigger one and I'd leave it to the
Constitutional law Scholars
okay I I completely understand and I
agree with you on that the only reason
that I bring it up is it seems like at
least to me in in the time that I've
spent on this Earth was just very short
um it seems like
we have sort of an ontological problem
in this country where we think that like
because something happened a long time
ago and it's been in place for a long
time that somehow it's better for it it
makes sense well that's conservatism in
a nutshell you know yeah it definitely
is and you know I've been reading about
the French republics and the different
you know constitutional conventions that
they've had over the years since they
founded their first Constitution and I
just it's just so refreshing to hear
about how they've done it and and the
maturity of that country and and I just
wish we could do that here and so we
wouldn't have to have conversations like
this where it's like well is one big
reform that's not going to happen good
or is a small reform that also probably
won't happen is that a good thing you
know no I completely agree with you and
I think one of the biggest problems in
even having many serious political
conversations in the United States is a
huge contingent that says that just
because it's what was done in the 18th
century we should of course assume that
it's the right way to do things today
you have to break through that before we
can seriously talk about a lot of
different things but uh Tristan I
appreciate the call a very important
elements uh questioned today
always great to hear from you David all
right there is Tristan from Washington
with a very powerful series of
declarations why don't we go next to is
it safe or safe from Detroit am I saying
that correctly
scythe
yes it's a safe safe uh welcome to the
program
thank you thank you I should uh I just
wanted to ask you about uh I don't know
if you read recently
I care about the Israel Palestine
conflict and
whether the acoustic solution has even
possible at this point I just wanted to
I was wondering if you had any thoughts
about that I I did not see the article
you said the the article is about what
the acoustic solution and uh basically
how we have to start thinking about the
reality of the cell 1C solution at this
point oh I I have not seen that article
no I haven't seen it
um I'm a two-state solution guy and I
have probably 20 Clips on my YouTube
channel about it so I don't have really
any like new material about it but I did
not see that article
yeah okay and I guess I'm just wondering
um
hello
okay
safe disappeared all right let's
continue next with uh how about Josh
from Florida Josh from Florida Welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hello can you hear me yes
perfect
um
yeah with uh DeSantis going you know
full
crazy I would say uh what what can we do
you know in upcoming elections to sort
of curb his you know power grab
are you saying power grab within Florida
or the idea of a power grab by running
and winning the Republican primary
um kind of both but I I'm thinking less
and less he's actually going to run for
president and if he does I'm thinking
less and less that he has a shot to win
I mean I I tend to agree with you on
that I mean here's the thing in Florida
Florida has become
an idea in a sense I don't know how else
to say it and it's of quite a right wing
idea the the thing even though Florida
has millions and millions of Democrats
and left leaning people and there are
beautiful left-leaning parts of Florida
Florida has become sort of the idea of
we're going to do whatever the hell we
want
and we're going to be anti-woke and
we're going to be for Freedom the way
they describe it freedom to spread covet
at UFC events I guess in the middle of a
pandemic whatever so the problem in
Florida to me is less about the
political makeup although it's quite
plausible that there are more
Republicans than Democrats but it's
about the strength that the right-wing
ideology has gained in Florida where a
lot of left-leaning people are just
disaffected and they're either thinking
about leaving or they just feel like
they politically don't have a home or
don't get involved in politics or
whatever the case may be so as a place
where many people move to Florida
obviously one approach would be have
more Democrats move to Florida and then
change the balance but it's not really
clear that that's a strategy I think it
really has to be about Democrats
rebuilding in Florida from the ground up
in a more modern way uh it's less about
like Debbie Wasserman Schultz's and and
more about some new type of Dem Democrat
I think there's going to have to be sort
of like a re-branding of Florida
Democrats in order to seize power back
from the way DeSantis has grabbed it
yeah the problem I feel is that
so many people look at
people who aren't you know progressives
Or democrats they look at a lot of stuff
and they go oh that's too radical for me
and and I'm like
what's so radical what's so radical
about
moving forward and progressing as a
society
yeah I mean here's the thing this goes
to what the caller earlier said
part of conservatism is conserving some
prior state of things now if you ask
them where is the pin that you would
drop in the timeline for what you want
to conserve some might say the 80s some
might say the 50s some might say right
before women could vote some could say
there were there were still slaves but
fundamentally it's the idea that we
should do things the way we used to do
them simply because it's the way we used
to do them and for a progressive that's
a fundamentally flawed idea
right I mean listen in think about all
of the areas in which we say it'd be
crazy to do things the way we used to
them in medicine we're going to do
things the way we used to do them
because that's how we used to do them in
terms of Transportation we're going to
get rid of planes and get rid of cars
and go to horses inter you know in all
of these different things uh we would
say that's crazy so why is it supposedly
acceptable in certain other areas I
think it's a flawed idea at its core
right
well I'm with you all right uh thank you
for everything you do Josh from Florida
thank you so very much for the call I
really do appreciate that why don't we
go next to
oh I don't know how about uh Adrian from
San Francisco Adrian from San Francisco
welcome to the program
thank you David I'm I'm not in the one
in South America
okay right you're in San Francisco
California
that's right how are you David I'm doing
well
David one thing I wanted to discuss with
you today was um a problem of
homelessness in California as a whole I
mean our state we've spent over 10
billion dollars in the past four years
on homelessness and oftentimes there's
sort of this perceived dichotomy of well
you can't you have to sacrifice safety
uh for Compassion or the other way
around so given that we spend so much
money but programs seem to be extremely
ineffective what's your take on terms of
number one the strategies to actually
solve this problem and number two why do
you think despite having spent so many
resources today we haven't really done
anything to to help solve or fix this
problem well homelessness is such a
complicated issue so it's interesting
you asked this on the Wednesday show we
covered Donald Trump's video where he
says he will create mandatory tent
cities which homeless people will be
brought to on buses and that's the
couldn't couldn't have a worse uh
solution to homelessness you're further
stigmatizing homeless people you're
taking them away from where the jobs are
those tent camps invariably become
overpopulated and sanitation becomes an
issue like that's the totally wrong
approach now what will work there's no
one thing that will work but a few
things that have to be done to deal
effectively with homelessness and part
of you know that you're asking why
hasn't the money spent worked if you
only do like one or two of these things
it doesn't work because you're not
actually solving the problem so we
really have to deal with why people
become homeless to begin with so number
one
affordability of housing housing is
really expensive in California and in
particular in the parts of California
that have the jobs and the people where
most people would try to be so you've
got to increase the availability of
affordable housing how you do it okay
you got to figure that out two expand
access to mental health and substance
abuse treatment have to do it we hear
about oh we're going to do it but like
how exactly do you do it what are the
programs is it properly funded and you
have to make sure people know about them
number three you've got to provide job
training and employment support just
getting you know you create a housing
place and you just give homeless people
housing great but are they actually at a
place where they can get themselves a
job and are they properly trained to
have a job and re-enter uh the workplace
particularly if they've been out of a
job for a decade and have been homeless
for a decade so you got to do the job
training and employment support you
probably need to do something about
folks kind of exiting the criminal
justice system
into homelessness there's like kind of
very mediocre halfway houses but there's
lack of stable housing for people when
they exit the the criminal justice
system so that would be number four and
then number five you probably need more
of a social safety net which has you
know temporary assistance food stamps
different things need to expand it
probably by uh getting services to more
people like that's a lot of stuff and
it's very easy to say like well we've
done some of that but you really need to
do all of it because homelessness is
such a complicated problem
you're you're absolutely right I agree
on all five of your points David but you
know one of the things that's
frustrating to me as a resident is that
you know the city of San Francisco
spends a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year per homeless person and
so you know the money is there we have
the money and the resources but somehow
it's not actually translating to
anything effective because those people
still need help those people are still
suffering on the streets and so
fundamentally there's this disconnect
where we see we're paying our taxpayer
dollars to try to help these people so
now hold on a second Adrian I'm not
finding that San Francisco spends 120
Grand a year per homeless person what I
am finding is that for the shelter beds
they're 70 grand a year per shelter bed
spent of course not all homeless people
are even participating in the shelter
system that's still a lot of money and
it seems like there's waste there but
I'm not I'm not finding that number that
you're you're pointing out
David is there a way I can later on
provide links or resources so we can
email info davidpackman.com I'll look
into that and listen you're a hundred
percent correct with the general
sentiment Adrian whatever the numbers
are that people's tax money is going
into what you are told or programs meant
to deal with an issue the issue isn't
being dealt with and I'm right there
with you on that whatever the numbers
are
great thanks so much David all right
Adrian from San Francisco
important issue let's take a very quick
break we're going to continue with the
phones in just a moment just hang on if
you're waiting to talk to me and we'll
be right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to the phones which are no longer
phones we now take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and hear from a few more people
why don't we go to Moni from the United
Kingdom from where I have just returned
Moni welcome to the program
hi uh how was your trip to the UK did
you actually go to Brighton in the end I
did not I ended up going to Bath in the
end
okay still a nice place yeah quite
interesting and you know the weather was
very shaky uh I actually I had an insane
situation where I was walking uh near
kind of near uh Regents Park in London
and it was so windy that my hotel
umbrella reversed have you've seen an
umbrella reverse right
oh like every couple weeks yeah yeah so
my umbrella reversed and it was I was
trying to hold on to the baby stroller
and the umbrella reversal was dragging
me around and these British girls walked
by and were laughing hysterically and it
I mean the the but then five minutes
later it was sunny you know I should
have helped you they should have helped
me I know they said beautiful day for a
walk that was their joke as I was
wrestling to try to keep the stroller
and the umbrella under control
funny you should say that the weather
here is awesome today oh yeah I saw that
the day I laughed it got better but
anyway what what can I do for you sir
um I just wanted to call in and say that
in the last like few I believe it's been
a few weeks now maybe even a month I
have do you agree that I I think that
this is possibly the biggest movement
for gun control in the US that I've seen
really uh since the uh
uh the two well they ended the
2004-2005 uh assault weapons ban I have
never seen uproar like this coming out
of I think it was the state of Tennessee
wasn't it you know it was I I want to
feel the same way you're feeling Moni
which is wow look at this isn't it we've
never seen momentum like this before it
seems inevitable that something's going
to be done but every time we think that
we're so disappointed like after the
Sandy Hook shooting about 11 years ago
it was like wow we're gonna pass
Universal background checks it's just
gonna happen and of course it it didn't
and you can go all the way back to the
civil rights movement of the 60s and 70s
and the assassinations of Martin Luther
King and Robert F Kennedy when there
were fewer guns in circulation and it
was like wow we're going to see change
and we did get the gun control act of
1968 regulating the the sale of firearms
and then we went on to have 400 million
guns enter Society in the United States
so I systems so cynical that we're
really going to see change I want to see
it and I hope that you're right
uh yeah me too man it's it's a bit crazy
over there we all see it it really does
the other thing I wanted to say if I do
have the time of course yeah I hope I do
yeah is um that with all these issues
that are going on recently with like the
whole thing of the Democrats playing to
of course put on the ballot supposedly
that they are pro-abortion rights and
all other things we've seen from Donald
Trump and all the things we've seen from
run to santis currently abandoning
Florida while it's underwater do you
think that a lot less people are going
to vote Republican in this next coming
election
now when you say that fewer people will
vote Republican do you mean that some
historical Republican voters will vote
for a Democrat or that many Republicans
will just stay home
uh well either really
I don't know the answer to that I mean I
do I do think that if Trump is the
nominee
which is looking quite likely it based
on today's polling I do think that there
is a contingent of the pub Republicans
that are just so sick and tired of the
insanity of trump now under indictment
potentially with more indictments coming
that they are going to throw their hands
up some of them and say listen I'm not
voting for a Democrat but I'm sick of
this Trump crap I'm just staying home I
do think there will be a contingent like
that whether it will influence the
results in any significant way it's just
so early to say
yeah I agree I had a friend from Georgia
who vote Republican most of his life he
actually switched in 2022 because of the
oh and just the abortion rights stuff so
yeah we will see yeah I'll I'll not take
up any more of your time now but thanks
for asking answering my questions all
right money from the UK have a good day
you too great to hear from you uh
absolutely fantastic stuff let's go next
to Louis from New Brunswick Louis from
New Brunswick welcome to the program
hey David
so good to uh to speak with you thanks
for taking the call my pleasure got a
couple questions I noticed on your show
uh could have been a couple days ago
you mentioned that you're leasing a
Tesla so there's more like a financial
question do you generally
um recommend that people lease vehicles
I heard it's a bad financial decision
overall no I recommend that people study
the issue on their own and make their
own decision based on how they tend to
deal with vehicles in their lives uh
leasing makes sense
for some people in very specific
situations one of the things about
leases is that uh they can be
fully tax deductible as a business
expense depending on the use of the
vehicle and how it's structured and that
is like a savings of whatever your
effective tax rate is which can be a
significant savings if you tend to
replace your vehicle with some frequency
leasing can be a much simpler path than
trying to sell a vehicle every few years
which you might be underwater on if
you're financing it and then you have to
deal with repairs or whatever like I
like after three years being able to
just walk away
um for me in particular I mean I'll be
honest I've said before I'm you know
former Tesla shareholder Tesla driver
the the build quality of my Tesla is not
exactly something to write home about
and it's been in the shop a bunch of
times and quite frankly I wouldn't want
to own it like there's a particular
reason with my Tesla I don't want to own
the thing I want to be able to just walk
away and it'll be Elon Musk or someone
else's problem at the end of three years
and at that by then there will be so
many
um other electric vehicles and the
quality will likely have improved and
the range that I'll sort of have like my
pick of the litter is my is my hope so
for for very specific reasons leasing
made sense for me but that doesn't mean
that it makes sense for any other
particular person
got you thank you for the detailed
response all right one more question if
we have time sure do you think there's
any chance that um facing the the threat
or like high possibility of imprisonment
that Donald Trump will flee the country
no that's your personal opinion I don't
believe so
gotcha
yep David it's been a pleasure thanks so
much take care Louie my PL the pleasure
is all on this side of the microphone my
friend I really appreciate that let's go
next to Jane from Hollywood Jane from
Hollywood welcome to the program what is
on your mind today
Jane from Hollywood I've invited you to
join us you do have to accept that
invitation and then we'll be able to
chat about whatever is on your mind
and last opportunity for Jane from
Hollywood please
all right a failed attempt with Jane
from Hollywood that is that is sad why
don't we try Ronald from Illinois Ronald
from Illinois welcome to the program
Ron please save us from the tech
troubles that are plaguing everyone
David can you hear yes I can
all right good good all right so I
um first first of all I want to say did
you enjoy your vacation I did enjoy it
thank you
all right that's good but um this news
with Clarence Thomas and Clarence Thomas
and all the Republicans that's being you
know like probably business put out do
you think that's Trump them doing it
sir you're saying do I think it's Trump
putting out these negative stories about
Clarence Thomas
about Clarence Thomas all the other
Republicans I mean just because he's
failing do you think that he's
intentionally bringing them down with
him I don't think so I mean that's an
interesting question which is Trump gets
arrested and indicted does he try to
take attention away from himself by
publishing all of this uh you know very
sketchy Financial activity by Clarence
Thomas I don't I I have no reason to
believe that's what's going on let me
put it that way
all right David that was my question
thanks all right there is uh Ronald from
Illinois great to hear from you let's go
next to mark from San Antonio Texas mark
from San Antonio welcome to the David
packman show
Mark please unmute yourself and then
I'll be able to hear you
hey David
um quick question you know I know the uh
the loan forgiveness thing is kind of uh
sketchy right now and up in the air but
really why do you think there's no
appetite from Congress to have any kind
of uh legislation around you know either
capping the amount that tuition can be
raised a year because it's exploding or
even you know taxing uh you know these
endowments I mean Harvard alone I think
through their endowment during covid by
13 billion dollars and all of this is
you know essentially tax money you know
the CEO of the Harvard management
company is the highest paid person
associated with the with the school I
mean why do you think there's no
appetite to go legislate that I mean I
can understand the private loan side of
it you know very much you know a lot to
be in bed with with Congress but you
know you know universities by and large
really can't donate to any kind of you
know uh political uh affiliation so I
don't want to be defeatist and I know
when I give you the reasons why we
aren't seeing those things people will
write to me and they'll say David if you
don't believe it can be done then of
course it won't happen you're gonna you
know depend take the wind out of the
sales now I'm going to tell you why it
hasn't been done for now and why it's a
difficult thing to do
um
putting a limit on how much tuition can
be increased
I I don't see how you could possibly
pass that Republicans would say you're
you're telling institutions how they
need to uh you know price their product
or service which of course is done there
are there are industries that are price
regulated but the opposition to that
would be absolutely off the charts in
order to tax the endowments of um these
institutions essentially what you're
talking about is a wealth tax I mean
remember that we already have different
types of taxes for different types of
financial transactions and some have no
tax but to say we're simply going to tax
the Holdings is a sort of wealth tax and
I just don't see any way in hell that
right now you get something like that
past doesn't mean that these are bad
ideas or we shouldn't try I'm not saying
activists shouldn't be calling for these
things but to answer the question of why
hasn't it happened it's because these
would be
such difficult things to get consensus
for from the current House and Senate of
the United States
right well thank you a quick drummer
question I'm a drummer myself
um you know I know you're a big fan of
Josh Ruiz but as far as a player um you
know who do you try to emulate the most
or stylistically sound like I don't
think I have any particular drummer I'm
trying to emulate I mean I think I you
know study so many different drummers
from so many different genres and time
periods but I couldn't really say
there's any any one uh any one person I
mean you know it's sort of like you're
gonna learn things from like Carter
Beauford from Dave Matthews Band that
are unique to Carter and they're going
to be completely different from the
things that you'll pick up from like a
Steve gadd or uh you know from watching
old Buddy Rich videos or whatever the
case may be so I think it's a sort of
consume everything sort of approach
yeah I mean I started off as a punk rock
drummer took a break from it for a while
when I came back I was like oh I can't
play that fast anymore and so then I
started kind of listening to some you
know like you've mentioned Steve gadd
and Kirk Beaufort and all those guys oh
that's interesting so you after the
morning after a break like you think
physically you can no longer play as
fast
correct yeah how old were you when you
took a break and how old were you when
you restarted
oh boy you just cut out I heard 30. what
was that
I started around 12 years old
um and I played up until I was 18 19 you
know sold my gear went to college and
then uh picked it back up I want to say
27. wow and then you had a diminished
physical capacity
right geez yeah I mean foot speed was
kind of gone and I'm sure if I I've
committed to it and you know really
tried I could get some of those chops
back but then it also it was just like a
complete disinterest in it fair fair all
right well we're gonna look into it
strongly
okay thanks very much appreciate the
call real quick let's go to Aubry from
Wisconsin many said do not speak to
Aubry again on the show but I'm just I
I'm tempted to hear what Aubry has to
say Aubry I don't have a ton of time but
what's on your mind today
wait that is so disrespectful
okay real quick um the first thing you
should I said is like the um Travis
Parker from blank 182 because he married
a Kardashian and Kardashians are the
best anyways
um I wanted to know your opinion on
um that settlement that Fox News came up
with with like
um Dominion do you think they're going
to stop like you know absolutely lying
no it is like Tucker calls so I'm gonna
be like hey I'm still like an
Entertainer so like I could say whatever
the shiznit I want yeah absolutely
listen Aubry it's not only that the
settlement between dominion and fox
doesn't even require Fox to apologize or
or say anything on air in a written
statement they said yeah the stuff we
aired wasn't true they're not even going
to take it back on air and so Tucker's
gonna keep doing his thing they'll talk
about Hunter Biden they'll talk about
you know low birth rates with Elon Musk
or whatever else they want it is good
it's not you is Fox going to stop lying
now is a hilarious question no they are
not going to stop blind
okay yeah okay so they're not going to
admit that they were just a clowns okay
cool real quick I'm completely offended
that people said don't talk to me
anymore um but I do appreciate it you
are an air sign so I feel like we get
each of those energies but wait I'm a
what what was that I'm an aristide so
you're an Aquarius and I'm a Libra
Rising so like we get each other's
energies in that way and I really
appreciate that
um but you're kind of the weird Arrow
sign which like you're kind of like kind
of snooty intellectual which I respect
but like that's fine and this is because
I'm an aquarius you're saying
yeah so essentially you're saying that
the perceived but possibly inaccurate
positions of stars and planets at the
time of my birth determine my
personality you don't have time but I
will start screaming about this
astrology is absolutely awesome we
experience so I'm a Libra Rising by
massager it's not which is why people
think I'm a Leo which is like some kind
of conceited but I will process this
because I'm a Libra Rising only Aries
men have ever tried it really hard with
me right like Pisces dudes I've been
with before but they're like
um Aries men have tried it super hardly
because excuse me I just I just let me
ask we'll end on this note okay I want a
yes or no and let me ask the full
question is that okay
okay
is your belief
that the perceived but possibly
inaccurate determination
about the position of stars and planets
at the time of my birth
dictates my personality today yes or no
absolutely all right there you go Aubry
from Wisconsin great to hear from you
bye bye there is Aubry from Wisconsin I
can't think of any better note than that
to end on thank you to everyone who
called in we will take calls again if I
have anything to say about it if they
let me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's look at some of your
feedback from the last week Friday
feedback featuring emails YouTube
comments Twitter replies subreddit posts
and all sorts of other ways that people
communicate with us you can always email
info davidpackman.com but your posts and
commentary on any of our platforms might
be selected we'll start with some
criticisms these are not exactly the
most classy criticisms John wrote in and
said do Alvin Bragg and David packman
watch three or four hours of porn every
day of their miserable lives get woke go
broke let's go Brandon now many of you
would say David there's nothing here to
actually address you're not you're not
right though get woke go broke as Farren
cousins so beautifully explained last
week this idea that quote getting woke
makes you go broke really doesn't seem
to be accurate and in fact we looked at
some very interesting polling data down
from Florida
which shows that despite the concerted
effort and attack campaign by Ron Des
Sanctus and other Republicans against
wokeness most Floridians and most
Americans actually agree with the
fundamental underlying reality of
wokeness which is I'm aware of problems
in society and that it would be great to
fix them and this sort of thing so that
it actually does seem that wokeness is
winning I address that in a segment a
few weeks ago as well as far as the
other stuff let's go Brandon and Alvin
Bragg's
habits or whatever I I don't know maybe
go ask someone who cares about that
stuff next email is from Mauricio who
wrote in about progressives and Firearms
this is a very interesting email says
hey David I'm a U.S Air Force veteran
with experience with a variety of
firearms I own a few guns mainly for
recreational purposes although there is
a self-defense element I consider myself
a progressive although I try to be
rational and like to hear other
perspectives to get to the root of
issues there are a few things I'm
interested in your perspective on what
is your perception of progressive gun
owners is this something you would
encourage discourage or are neutral
about is there any message you have for
Liberal gun owners well I have many
liberal gun owning friends I as I've
said before on the show I I don't really
talk about my ownership or lack thereof
of firearms I just I just don't I don't
see any reason to necessarily talk about
it I've opted not to mention whether I
do or don't own firearms but one of the
things I have said before
is I would like the entire situation
around Firearms to be different it
should be much more expensive training
and Licensing should be much more
extensive you should be required to have
insurance if you have firearms there
should be limits on more limits on what
Firearms people can buy and in
particular people under age 25 I've
given all that list and if I were a
firearm owner myself I would be more
than willing to subject myself to all of
those requirements as well I would
prefer there be way fewer guns in
circulation
and dramatically so
given the status quo today
I don't love the idea
of the right Wingers being the only ones
with the Firearms like that doesn't
sound good either and it's not about
government tyranny because I think that
that's quite a silly argument but it's
if you zoom out and you say there's 400
million firearms in this country do I
want
370 million of them in the hands of
right Wingers including a lot of
right-wing nuts no that doesn't sound
particularly good so I get that this is
sort of like a race to the bottom type
thing well so if the Liberals got the
guns then the I get it believe me I get
it given where things are
I don't want the right Wingers to be the
only ones with the guns call me crazy
next email is from James writing about
2024 and says given both bidens and
Trump's Ages come the next election
there's a real possibility that either
one or both could have to pull out due
to ill health or Worse pass away last
minute what chaos do you feel could
follow thanks Jim from Ireland yeah
listen statistically speaking it is more
likely that people in their late 70s or
early 80s will die than someone who's 45
statistically that is absolutely the
case whether this is likely you know we
we looked at Actuarial tables uh looking
at Joe Biden and Donald Trump's ages and
it is still
it is still more likely than not that
they will survive to the next election
but there is no doubt that if either if
either is or both were the nominees and
if either were to die close to the time
of the election or even imagine between
the election and the inauguration it
would be chaotic and this is less about
the law and more about I mean listen if
Trump's winning by four
and November 1st 2024 he dies and
Republicans scramble and they put in I
don't know who hard to imagine a
scenario where I don't know who actually
wins same thing would apply to Joe Biden
so I think that that would be the most
likely outcome that if uh one of the
candidates if a nominee were to die at a
very late stage of the campaign
um it's unlikely that whoever replaces
them is going to win that that I think
is the most likely outcome the myth
wrote in and said sorry to hear that you
don't have a channel anymore about the
YouTube channel I also heard about this
from John who says is it true you got
kicked off YouTube no uh so several
weeks ago now we did an April Fool's
joke saying the right-wing mob won and I
lost my YouTube channel now the truth is
you can't really lose your YouTube
channel or get kicked off you could get
banned from YouTube for publishing
content repeatedly that's in violation
of YouTube's terms and conditions but
it's an important thing to remember that
they can't really take your YouTube
channel from you or shut it down and I
am really thrilled to be able to say
that actually the channel had its best
month in a really long time in March
April is looking incredible you know not
long ago
I had the goal of saying I want to
steadily get a million views a day on
YouTube steadily not just like oh here's
a good day we got a million but we're
averaging way fewer
we've recently been averaging close to
1.5 million views per day on the YouTube
channel which is stunning and I have
only you to think so fortunately the
YouTube channel is alive and well let's
look at a YouTube comment this one's
from thar CX4 UK uq
who says about the North Carolina
elected official who switched party from
democratic to Republican as a politician
you shouldn't be allowed to switch
parties midterm you should only be
allowed to do it when running for
re-election that way the voters know who
they are voting for it's an interesting
idea understand that you would of course
have to announce that
you could be a Democrat
if you announce that you're running for
re-election a year before the election
you would be announcing then I'm running
as a republican so you're still sort of
making it known just as early and you
could still vote however you wanted so
while it's an interesting idea from thar
I don't know that in Practical terms it
really solves the issue that I think
they're getting at
feedback about last week's guest hosts
the good news as I mentioned on the
bonus show on Monday is that almost
everybody who wrote in about last week's
guest hosts which included producer Pat
Luke Beasley and Faron cousins almost
everybody who wrote in said I I liked at
least one of them and that's a really
great thing Michael says Pat and Luke
did the best jobs of handling the show
hands down pat being the better of the
two but both were more true to your
demeanor I would much rather see these
two guest hosts alternate alternate days
assuming it's difficult to prepare daily
so that's Michael
um Stephen wrote in and said providing
feedback that I much prefer Luke as a
host the reason for this is that I watch
your show for political commentary with
a progressive touch Faron cousins comes
off as a left-wing preacher and it's
very off-putting his Vibe just doesn't
match the show you or Pat with two T's
so a lot going on spelling wise but a
very interesting bit of feedback and
then other people wrote in and said
farron's the only one that I watched
other people wrote it and said you know
the problem with farron and Luke is they
have their own channel so then I end up
seeing they cover the stories and then
they cover them for you and it doesn't
make sense but the whole idea was
something for everyone
and I would call it an unmitigated
success but we'll keep trying different
formulations in the future lastly a post
from reflex point on the subreddit who
says I was impressed with Gavin Newsom I
get the feeling he's gearing up to be in
line for a 2028 run or even 2024 if
something were to happen to Biden before
the election I think this interview he
had with Brian Tyler Cohen was very good
and worth watching he has a fighting
spirit that I think Dems need and he's
not afraid to take the fight to the
right and put him on the defensive even
if it's not him we need someone that is
not afraid to be confrontational with
Republicans Brian Tyler Cohen's
interview with Gavin Newsom was
excellent I recommend you check that out
and I tend to agree and as I've said
before I don't think Gavin Newsom is the
be-all end-all of the progressive
politician of the future I think he has
policy areas where I agree policy areas
where he's sort of like okay
but the critical thing about Newsome is
he is willing to be ruthless in the way
that the left should be ruthless when it
comes to these Republicans that's a very
good thing not everybody's willing to do
it so I think Newsom is a very
interesting guy although I don't think
he is the Uber Progressive
um but there are many considerations
when we think about who would make a
good nominee how they would handle
attacks from Republicans is an important
part of that how what would their
demeanor be in debates important part of
that all of those things very very
interesting candidate potential
candidate he's not he hasn't announced
that he's running uh send me your
thoughts info davidpackman.com
post to the subreddit or leave a comment
on YouTube or whatever the case may be
please remember
to ensure that you were subscribed to
the YouTube channel hit that subscribe
button we are pushing our way slowly to
2 million subscribers and also remember
that much of our content is available in
Spanish at davidpackman.com Spanish if
you know anyone who would like or
benefit from this content but would
better consume it in Spanish rather than
English let them know about
davidpackman.com Spanish we will see you
on the bonus show in your moments
thank you